okay let's get to our big Jenga thing
and I think we've got people knocking at
the door we've got crazy stuff going on
it's crazy what's going on in here Pat
it's it's unbelievable but we're doing a
show here so if people are gonna break
the door down then I'm gonna keep making
Jenga moves the game has been as follows
we are contributing contributions
through a platform called patreon that's
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
and what we've been doing is I have a
Jenga tower on my desk and for every two
patreon contributions I've been moving
one piece I've so far moved 29 pieces 29
gets doubled to 58 and if I am NOT able
to move any more pieces we will create a
58 percent discount code for membership
for people okay that's the idea I have
one question if you're able to move more
than 50 pieces does that mean that you
have to start paying people for
membership yes and of course it's not
it's just impossible because it that it
will have toppled over at that point it
is mathematically impossible for that
for that to happen I believe but we will
see okay so we now have oh I got a
message from a couple people saying that
there's a particular piece over here
that I should easily be able to move
it's not moving that that piece is
deadlocked in place so forget about that
piece okay we have some new contributors
and I'm going to start moving pieces and
we really thought this was gonna fall
late last week and it did give me the
first two names Pat and I'll see what I
can do here let me get set up and get
closer to this thing Patrick Roy and
Bailey Watson okay it's just so tight
right now and I know people say if you
touch a piece or something you've got to
move that piece but I'm not I'm not
playing with those rules let's see if
there's any piece and as you can see the
entire tower is teetering and tottering
right now and Pat looks so nervous it's
and we'll see how nervous Pat looks oh
no oh that's it no is it that looks
shocked at what just took place that's
it
29 pieces was it and it has crumbled and
that Pat looks like he's going to cry
honestly it's I don't know upset about
this or did it just stun you that it
happened so quickly now you had a couple
moves left I apologize that I've not
able I have not been able to do better
but we got through 29 moves
this was a crazy idea wasn't it and the
entire thing fell and during the
commercial break we will vacuum up all
of these pieces that's a whole other
thing which I'm going to be performing
just for Pat it will be an interpretive
vacuuming up of Jenga wood so we do have
we're gonna set up a coupon code it'll
be for a 58 percent discount and it will
be Jenga 58 je nga 5/8 and we will allow
people to sign up at a 58 percent
discount for the membership of their
choice on our website what we let it run
till the end of the weekend yeah like
that I mean I was speaking to accounting
I don't think we can afford a 58 percent
discount yeah only if you give back some
of those 300,000 memberships you've
picked up can we afford that doesn't
even make any sense I don't know what
I'm talking about now I am a little
distraught by this I was hoping to have
to have another another couple moves but
29 moves 58 percent discount the coupon
code is Jenga 58 and what why is this so
funny to you Pat that's just cracking
himself up with this I just love this
whole idea yeah all right well Jenga 58
je nga 58 we'll get this all cleaned up
and then we will get back to the show
after the break